well you probably thought because you're
basically silly and not a licensed
epidemiologist that if you got the
chronovirus vaccine you could
live like a normal human being again but
no we've got some bad news for you
science denier
the people in charge are not going to
give up the power they now have
that easily that was the message today
very clearly from msnbc's resident
medical expert dr vin gupta who by the
way is the exact same title as
dr jill biden just because you get
vaccinated with that second dose
does not mean you should be
participating in things like
traveling in the middle of an out of
control pandemic or that you're
liberated from masks
everything still applies until all of us
get the two dose regimen so really
really critical
don't let your guard down just because
you got vaccinated
uh-huh so just because you take the
rushed vaccination they're gonna require
you to take
don't think you're liberated from mask
you will never
be liberated from masks plebe
that's the whole point submit and obey
indefinitely
sounds dark but over the summer a guy
called
dave portnoy presciently predicted this
very thing would happen
what the [ __ ] going on when did this
become
flatten the curve flatten the curve
flatten the curve to we have to find a
cure
or everyone's going to die find a carer
who says we're going to find a cure
people been mentally preparing we're
doing what you asked we've done exactly
what you said
now you're changing the rules
wow dave portnoy does not work at the
cdc he is instead the founder of
barstool sports
and we're happy to have him on for a
victory lap tonight dave having
predicted this exact same thing and when
you said that i thought
i don't know that's kind of dark dave
portnoy really
but you were right
yeah you know i won't call it a victory
lap at this point
um you know you know nobody
and i don't really care what affiliation
you are nobody should be happy right now
my latest
you know rant is really new york
announced no more indoor dining um
they're shutting that down
uh indefinitely and you know i as a
small business guy he was turned
barcelona to maybe
a little bit bigger i i feel bad for all
these people who aren't being given the
chance
restaurants bars to earn a living and
you know i i don't know what government
officials politicians expect these
people to do
my heart truly breaks for them and i've
spoken a lot of them they want they just
want the chance to work
um you know you've seen stats that like
90 of bars and restaurants
are never going to come back in new york
city and you know
there's no great answer right now to
what's going on clearly with corona
but the solution of just saying nobody
can basically go to restaurants and bars
that that doesn't sit well with me it
doesn't sit well with any of the owners
they want a plan they've done
everything that government officials
have asked to do along with the
flattening curve
but with restaurants you know you have
to wear the mask less tables
six feet of separation they've built
outside structures on their own dimes
they've restarted they're trying to pay
their employees and then
all of a sudden hey sorry uh you can't
even do indoor dining what do you
suppose we have a blizzard coming here
tomorrow in new york city
um you know for the snow whatever so you
just you can't earn a living
there has to be a way there has to be a
solution
there's no stimulus and by the way a lot
of these people don't even want just a
government
paycheck they want the opportunity to
earn a living
and that's the part that's crazy and
that's the part that has to be fixed
like
stop everything that and it's not
democrat not republican
because both of them own businesses
restaurants bars you have to figure out
a way
to let these people survive i get corona
i get all
but just to destroy livelihoods that
have taken decades to build
i don't know how this isn't something
that everyone sits around at a table
every single day until you figure out a
solution to let these people live
i do not understand that i mean after a
while people are going to get the
message don't bother
trying to start a small business just go
work in an amazon warehouse
it's bad for the society i think over
time what are what can we do about it
you know and we've been looking at that
a lot so i got channels to donate money
and there's different solutions that
we're looking at right now whether it be
you help with rent
whether it be you donate money for them
to make meals for maybe
people who who are hungry so feed the
famished a little bit
and they can make you know basic meals
like chicken and rice and and spend the
money that way
so we're evaluating it all right now in
ways that we can help and we're going to
try to raise a lot of money
and give it to these restaurant owners
again i keep looking at maybe it hits
home a little bit because of barstool
and the way i grew it
but these family-run businesses that
have been
you know decades been run for decades
just getting wiped out
and the answer seems to be sorry we hit
a pandemic i get it unique circumstances
but there is no pla the only people who
are working to create
plans seem to be the people affected
and a lot of the politicians who have
preached one thing and done another
don't go on vacation don't go out to eat
then you're at the french laundry
a lot of these people they haven't come
up with the solutions it's the
restaurant owners
in the bar owners and the people being
put out of business
who are spending every second you see
them all over the place
work with us we're trying to come to
solutions and no no nobody's helping
them
if you figure out a way to help i hope
you'll come back and tell us what it is
because i think a lot of people
absolutely want to help dave portnoy
thank you